aprobar o rechazar la nueva constitución
es la decisión que más de 15 millones de
chilenos habilitados para votar deben
tomar el próximo 4 de septiembre el
nuevo texto propone la declaración de
chile como un estado social democrático
de derecho y plurinacional representando
una victoria política para los pueblos
indígenas del país quienes contaron con
17 escaños para redactar la constitución
pero tras el arresto de héctor llaitul
líder del pueblo mapuche acusado de
supuestamente incitar a rebelión y de
pertenecer a una organización criminal
algunos seguidores de la nueva
constitución se manifestaron en las
calles de santiago
no nos van a permitir nunca más salir a
la calle porque que un gobierno
represivo igual que los anteriores
también tenemos preso político mapuche
las apuestas sociales de la nueva carta
magna intentan pasar la página de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet en la que
nació la actual constitución y
capitalizar las demandas del estallido
del 18 de octubre de 2019
ahora chile podría contar con una
democracia partidaria en el que las
mujeres tendrían que ocupar el 50 por
ciento de los órganos del estado con un
proceso constituyente que ha sido
marcado recuerda involucrarnos de manera
paritaria en su proceso de construcción
y por lo tanto hemos
visto que se han visibilizado todos
nuestros derechos que hemos luchado a
través de los movimientos feministas
movimientos de mujeres
pero a 8 días de los comicios la
población chilena está dividida yo no
creo que la solución pase por escribir
algo en un pleno un texto que realmente
necesitamos a políticas públicas buenas
esta jornada electoral será la primera
en diez años en la que el voto es
obligatorio un reto para los indecisos
que representan una importante parte de
la población habilitada para votar